hey guys it's a new garyvaynerchuk.com
time appreciate you watching
first and foremost just want to take a
quick second action just thank you for
watching these videos because if people
didn't watch it they were zero viewed I
probably want to make them so I think
way too many people that have been
fortunate enough to have a platform of
even twenty five people consuming their
content
don't thank their audience enough and I
want to do that right now thank you so
much for thinking that I bring enough
value that you take time out of your day
to listen the other day I said that
treat everybody like a goldfish and a
lot of people were like huh
ma you know people are like what uh and
he was where I went with this last
Saturday as I was leaving for a family
function somebody tweeted out that they
unsubscribed garyvaynerchuk.com
and I just tweeted back to them thanking
them for ever watching in the first
place kind of where I was coming from
work I just started this video with and
uh and then it got to the front feed
which I thank him because I've learned
more about friend feed from it and I
liked it uh and he made an interesting
comment in there he said wow Gary I'm
shocked you even care I'm just such a
small fish in a big pond and I kind of
hit me that rationale that people think
that and that that's how people make
decisions on who they engage with or who
they think is worth the time spending
for and I think that's pure insanity and
I think whether your individual brand a
small business or a consumer brand
products CPG you need to really consider
every user out there it's not about the
big television buy or the billboard
anymore people are now expecting a
higher level of engagement and that's
how they make their decisions and kind
of the way I've got about it is that I
want to treat everybody to the best of
my ability because I'm only human and
only so scalable but to the best of my
ability just a little Bowl OOP
somebody's going two or three number
treat everybody like a goldfish you know
if you do treat everybody like it's one
huge big-ass ocean and there's lots of
fish you may focus on the whales right
and some of the tiger sharks and hammer
shark and some of the other big fish may
be interesting to you big fat tuna you
know but if you treated every person you
do business with and every client you
have and every heavy an enthusiastic
user of your product out there as a
goldfish as a one within a little you
will be in a totally different place
your brand will be you know think about
the emotional attachment
you had to your goldfish they felt that
the goldfish felt the love and I think
that's how the users out there the
customers the clients the people of our
world now because of this insane
connection want to feel and that's how
they're gonna pick their brands who's
feeding them who's looking at them who
gave them a little castle to go through
who gave a crap if you treat everybody
like a goldfish you will have a bigger
business period end of story
talk to you later